[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory let
me start off by saying a big thank you
to all of you for all of your support
with the channel does past couple of
months in this video we're going to be
addressing the question how did Harry's
expel yamas match Voldemort
Avada Kedavra in the graveyard scene in
the Goblet of Fire what's interesting
about this scene is that it almost
suggests that Harry is Voldemort equal
but that is really not the case so how
did he contend with the Dark Lord
himself as we know his scene marks the
proper return of Lord Voldemort after a
long hiatus before this point in time
Voldemort had still been trapped in
other weaker forms first a wisp like
form and then his rudimentary form a
form that only barely gave him a
physical presence as we know the Goblet
of Fire outlines the events as a
triwizard tournament the tournament that
Harry was competing in as a
representative for Hogwarts what Harry
did not know however was that while
participating in the tournament he was
being given a winner's advantage one of
Voldemort's followers Barty Crouch jr.
did everything in his power to ensure
that Harry were in the / winner in the
hedge maze and turned the Triwizard Cup
into a portkey this port key would lead
to little Angleton the same place that
Voldemort was undergoing his
transformation into his proper form more
specifically it was the graveyard of the
Langille ttan the burial ground of
Voldemort's father Tom Riddle senior
their location was of particular
importance in this setting as it played
an integral role in Voldemort return to
a proper physical form
you see Vohland could not truly return
until he was given a regeneration potion
an ancient dark potion and helps restore
wizards for their bodies it just so
happened that little Angleton was the
location of one of the most important
ingredients in the potion bone of father
the potion as a whole required three
ingredients bone of father flesh of
servant and blood of foe to create this
potion Wormtail and Barty Crouch jr.
helped
Voldemort source these ingredients they
were able to create the potion
successfully by using worm tails to
flesh Voldemort's father's bone and
harry's blood all of the ingredients
were then placed inside of the cauldron
and Baltimore's rudimentary form was
placed inside Harry's blood being in the
potion is an important part of this
video so remember that when Harry first
arrives in the graveyard cedric came
along with him
however cedric didn't last long as he
was nearly immediately struck with the
nevada Kedavra cast by Pettigrew on
Voldemort's command as you can imagine
harry was not having a good time after
assuming his new all-powerful form
Volant summons an array of death eaters
and begins to address Harry Voldemort in
typical Ford walk fashion begins his
monologue and essentially proclaims that
Harry's survival 13 years prior was
purely a fluke I think that Voldemort
was doing this weird peacocking to prove
to the Death Eaters that he was still
powerful and that he wouldn't be outdone
again or would he Voldemort then ordered
Wormtail to release Harry then gave him
his wand effectively initiating a duel
with Harry you have been taught how to
duel Harry Potter we bow to each other
Harry come the niceties must be observed
Dumbledore would like you to show
manners bow to death Harry after
taunting Harry and asking him to bow he
eventually used the Imperius curse on
him forcing him to bow shortly after
that he performed another of the
unforgivable curses on Harry the
Cruciatus curse initially Harry tried to
escape and found himself hiding behind
the gravestone however he quickly
realized that he would have to stay and
fight understanding that there was no
easy way out this situation additionally
he was angry about the murder of Cedric
and wanted to exact revenge
Harry stepped out from behind the
gravestone and immediately started
uttering his incantation expel yamas he
yelled pawning his wand Awards Voldemort
however just as Harry cast his spell
Voldemort cast his own Avada Kedavra he
screamed the spells collided so what
happened next
well let's start with the passage from
the book
a jet of green light issued from
voldemort's wand just as a jet of red
light blasted from harry's they met in
midair and suddenly Harry's wand was
vibrating as though an electric charge
were surging through it his hands seized
up around it
he couldn't have release it if he'd
wanted to and a narrow beam of light
connected the two ones neither red nor
green but bright deep gold at this point
in time Harry couldn't let go of his
wand and neither could Voldemort the
pair were raised into the air and moved
to a clear piece of ground away from the
graves
andthe beam of light connecting their
ones turned into a golden webbed Dome at
this point in time Voldemort commands
the Death Eaters not to interfere
Voldemort unsure of what is happening
frantically attempts to break the
connection between the ones but is
unsuccessful Harry who is also unaware
of what exactly is happening gets the
impression that he cannot let the
connection between the wands break
despite it being progressively harder
and harder to maintain beads of light
move up the web dome toward Harry and he
gets the feeling that he cannot let
those beads contact his wand so he
focuses his mind and pushing them back
toward Voldemort after concentrating
like he never had in his life
Harry managed to force one of the beads
back onto Voldemort wand this resulted
in his wand emitting echoing screams of
pain Harry sees an apparition of
Wormtail silver hand and next a
ghost-like apparition of Cedric Diggory
and then he sees more faces Cedric
along with Frank Bryce and Bertha
Jorkins instruct Harry to keep fighting
next Harry's mother Lily Potter appears
also encouraging Harry to hold on she
tells Harry to wait for his father and
the other shades begin to distract
Voldemort
when James finally appears he tells
Harry that they will be able to linger
and keep Voldemort away for a short time
but not for long and that he should try
and move towards the portkey at this
point in time Harry effectively breaks
the connection between the two ones and
makes a run for the portkey just as
Voldemort begins to raise his wand Harry
shouts a summoning charm bringing him
the Triwizard cup that he uses to escape
just in the nick of time so what
happened there we know that Voldemort is
using Avada Kedavra so how is Harry able
to defend himself against it we first
learn about the properties of Avada
Kedavra in the copper to fire in class
moody actually Barty Crouch jr. is
teaching the class about the
unforgivable curses and clearly states
that there is no way to fend off the
killing curse sure you can block a
vertical dive by moving objects in its
path but blocking it with counter spells
that's supposed to be out of the
question
let's just kick things off by saying
that Voldemort was not yet in possession
of the Elder Wand so that wasn't really
a factor to consider in other scenes
like in the Battle of Hogwarts Harry
being the true owner of the Elder Wand
while Voldemort was in its possession
meant that Harry had the upper hand
however in the graveyard scene that
wasn't the case so again how did Harry's
Miko expelliarmus match Voldemort's
unforgivable killing curse the answer to
this question is relatively
straightforward and comes down to a
couple of things the first thing is once
again his mother Lily Potter
miraculously bails Harry out again with
her unyielding love or at least as part
of it as we know Voldemort used a
regeneration potion to reconstruct his
body one ingredient this potion was
blood of foe which basically means that
Voldemort used Harry's blood to
reconstruct his body this also would
have been the same blood that belonged
to Lily Harry's mother when
reconstructing his body Baltimore
thought that this would work to his
advantage that it would shield him from
her these same sacrificial protection
that destroyed him many years prior he
also thought that this meant that he
would be able to properly attack Harry
what happened instead was that he
rendered Harry the only person capable
of killing him and turned himself into a
Horcrux of sorts for Harry
this meant that as long as he was alive
Harry could not die so that's the first
reason their blood bond
the second reason comes down to once
once again although Voldemort was not
yet in possession of the Elder Wand he
did possess his wand which actually
happens to share the same core as
Harry's wand
volleyballs 1 was the brother 1 to
Harry's so to speak
you might remember Ollivander alluding
to
this in the Philosopher's Stone I
remember every wand I've ever sold mr.
Potter every single one and it just so
happens that the Phoenix whose
tailfeather resides in your wand gave
another feather just one other it is
curious that you should be destined for
this wand when it's brother gave you
that scar what can occur when two
brother ones go into contact with each
other is a phenomenon called priori
Incantatem which is also known as the
reverse spell effect this is exactly
what happened to Harry and Voldemort in
the Copts of fire if two Wizards are
fighting each other and this occurs they
are effectively locked into a battle of
wills the spouse become intertwined when
they meet and the connection is hard to
break at this point the wand of the
Wicca combatant will begin to display in
a ghostly format the spells that have
been cast by said wand in order of most
recent to least recent this is the
reason that Harry's parents appeared and
the reason they were able to interact
with the physical world additionally
when the spells meet they will produce
the dome effect mentioned earlier which
acts as a safeguard to prevent other
witches and wizards from intervening the
golden thread connecting Harry and
Voldemort splinted though the ones
remained connected a thousand mobiums
arced high over harry and voldemort
criss crossing all around them until
they were enclosed in a golden dome
shaped web a cage of light so for those
two reasons
harry was both safe from Voldemort and
even beat him in a way through having a
stronger will it's not always just about
how powerful your spell is and this is
just a perfect example of that as it
shows an instance in which is seemingly
basic spell like expel yamas is able to
best
Avada Kedavra and that's it for this
video I hope that answers the question
if you enjoyed the content please
remember to like the video and subscribe
to the channel until next time you're a
wizard Harry
[Music]
you